good morning believe nation today's
message is be true to you over to you
kid kudi you know I I just wanted to
make music that was true to me and
however that applied in other people's
lives you know I just wanted people to
take whatever inspiration they got from
it and applying into the worlds and grow
and I wanted people to see me grow as an
adult through the music what you do
should always be a reflection of who you
are I'm going to say that again because
it's important what you do should always
be a reflection of who you are you see a
lot of entrepreneurs hang on for too
long you may have been passion about
something in the past and you dumped a
lot of time and a lot of money into it
and now it's scary to leave and do
something else and to evolve your
business because you think about all
that investors that you put in that time
and those dollars are gone you're not
getting them back and if you continue to
do the things that you're not passion
about anymore just because that's the
way you used to do it you're never going
to build anything great you have to
evolve your business as you evolve of a
human being and that's going to happen
if you look at my company it's changed
so many times over the past decade I
started off with just a website and that
was I was all in on the web and then I
moved to LinkedIn and then I'm up to
facebook and i moved to twitter and i am
all in on youtube and even the topics
that i've talked about have changed over
the years and the passion I've delivered
them with have changed over the years my
business is always a reflection of Who I
am which is part of the reason why i'm
happy i called my website Evan
Carmichael calm as I change my business
changes with me as you change your
business has to change with you you
can't hold on to the same things that
you're doing before just because you put
a lot of time and money into it your
business has to evolve as you evolve
that's the only way you're going to
accomplish anything great believe so my
question today for you today is I want
to know how you've changed with your
business what change in your personal
life change
who you are led to a change in what
you're doing in your company i'm really
curious to find out leave it in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events beso